let's hear from jordan from first after  the draw against pragnanda  you didn't this turned into quite the  defensive battle how'd you get away from  this uh yeah i wasn't sure what was  going on but i was definitely under  pressure so  draws black is okay i guess and um yeah  it wasn't an easy game and now you have  confidence  no not too much but i have a white game  next so i'll try to do something there  thank you thank you you sounded like you  were either listening to music or  enjoying your position there at one time  what was it was it was that music  playing in the ears  no i didn't uh put music on uh if i put  the music on it would be disturbing so i  didn't have it on  one and a half points you  happy um games could have been better  but yeah it's it's a good position to be  on  good luck hey thanks